[Music]
635
light years from where you are sitting
way out there in outer space lies a
planet
the first planet to be discovered within
the habitable zone of a sun-like star
its name is kepler-22b
when a planet is located within a star's
habitable zone
it means there's a chance that liquid
water exists on its surface
and where there's water there's also the
possibility of life
human life
how long would it take to get to
kepler-22b
what would the weather be like over
there
and why would you need to get jacked
before arriving on this new planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you live on kepler-22b
kepler-22b is what scientists call an
exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system
spotting an exoplanet like kepler-22b is
often not easy
the bright glare of the stars they orbit
tends to keep them hidden from our
telescopes
what did scientists come up with to get
around it
looking at the stars themselves to see
if they can find anything unusual about
them
they spotted kepler-22b using what's
called the transit method
they watched kepler-22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time
that was because kepler-22b was blocking
the star's light
with this scientists were able to learn
both the size of 22b and how it orbits
and it looks like this distant space
rock could become our next home
okay but what do we really know about
kepler-22b
its mass is 36 times that of earth with
a radius of two and a half times larger
than ours
one year on kepler-22b is 290 days
it's also located 15
closer to its star than we are to the
sun
if earth scooched over that close to our
star
you'd be fried
kepler-22b on the other hand is lucky to
have a sun that is remarkably similar to
ours but also smaller and cooler
this close proximity to its star allows
the planet to receive about the same
amount of sunlight as we get over here
the temperature on kepler-22b could be
about 15 to 22 degrees celsius
similar to earth's spring weather and
quite habitable if you ask me
but our galaxy can be a cruel place and
not everything is good news
some models suggest kepler-22b
is rotating on its side
kind of like our very own uranus
this may sound insignificant but it adds
potentially deadly complications
this would mean that its north and south
poles are shrouded in either darkness or
sunlight for half a year
and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person
a world like kepler-22b spinning on its
side means that temperatures could
change from boiling to freezing
which wouldn't be great for human life
i know what a bummer but don't despair
yet because our galaxy is also big
enough to include some hope
new studies suggest that kepler-22b
might be covered in an ocean 50 meters
deep
and that ocean would be able to act as
natural climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at bay
you see an ocean can store heat in the
summer and release it during the winter
which results in a mild climate
like you needed another reason to live
close to the water
but hold on how would you even make it
all the way to kepler 22b
i mean even if you were traveling at the
speed of light it would take you
635 years
your best bet could be to hibernate
through the trip inside a device that
preserves your body way past its natural
lifespan
like cryogenic sleep
nasa has already developed a cryo-sleep
chamber that can lower an astronaut's
body temperature to as low as 32 degrees
celsius
this would trigger natural hibernation
during which catheters would provide
your body with nutrients and
remove any waste
but even in cryosleep it would be quite
the long risky trip
this leads us to the most dangerous part
about this journey
all that remains unknown about
kepler-22b
for starters we still don't really know
what gravity is like there
it could be twice as strong as our
planets
if that was the case a 10 kilogram sack
of potatoes would now weigh 20 kilograms
and your body would also factor into the
mix
is your current weight 75 kilograms
well good luck suddenly dealing with 150
kilograms of you
and just for safety settlers such as
yourself would need to bulk up
really bulk up
only through intense strength training
would you increase your chances of being
able to walk on kepler 22b
and once you got jacked on earth you'd
have to figure out ways to preserve that
muscle through all
635 years of light speed travel
but humans aren't the only life form
that would be affected by a stronger
gravity
plants brought from earth for oxygen and
nutrition might not survive on
kepler-22b when you try growing them
there
and if you brought any animals with you
they'd need to step up the evolution
process
higher gravity could lead to creatures
developing additional legs to move
around
it could also determine the location and
size of internal organs
but the mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that kepler-22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gaseous similar to neptune
or it could be entirely covered with
water
if you and the other first settlers woke
up from your cryosleep and found
yourself on a gas planet
yeah that would be a downer
you wouldn't have a solid surface to
even land your ship
not to mention a place to set up camp
in that case you and your crew would
need to figure out how to build a cloud
city orbiting the planet
if you landed on an ocean planet a
submarine town would be in order
discovering kepler-22b is a rocky planet
would be hitting the jackpot then right
well not so fast
venus is also made of rock and yet its
dense atmosphere consisting of
greenhouse gases makes it uninhabitable
with scorching temperatures far too hot
for liquid water
if this was also the situation with
kepler-22b
our only chance at thriving on this
exoplanet would be to employ robots that
could build underground shelters
the place where maybe
just maybe the temperature might be cool
enough for you to bear
it just goes to show you that a prime
location is no guarantee for human
survival
and as exciting as it might seem to find
other worlds to inhabit our own earth
remains the perfect habitat for humanity
but sometimes the slightest change can
shake its ideal balance
just turn off the oxygen supply for five
seconds and a raging sunburn is in the
cards for you
but
that's a story
for another
what if
you